townhall.com senior reporter julio
Rosa's has been on the ground for days
covering the chaos in Seattle he joins
us now julio that video is shocking but
what's even more so is a Councilwoman
was standing right there and said
nothing yeah no exactly there's a lot of
craziness going on right now from what
I've seen today they're the people
inside the autonomous zone at Capitol
Hill they're trying to figure out what
to do next because now they've held this
the six block radius for a few days now
and now they're just getting to on what
the next stages in their plans are and
so at first this morning if things were
relatively calm they were breaking off
into groups oh I'm talking about
different things on what the next steps
are but things kind of got a little
tense when some Seattle police officers
came inside the zone to go inside the
east precinct to get some stuff out of
their office at that point half the half
of the crowd wanted to make sure that
nothing happened to the officers but the
other half of the crowd was asking well
what are they doing here this is our
zone this is our territory this goes
against everything that we've been doing
the past few days and there were
arguments breaking out on whether or not
they shouldn't be letting them in and
now as I've posted on social media is
there's been a lot of arguments within
their little town hall that they've set
up on again just what the next steps are
right now there's no clear decisive
leadership inside so things are really
kind of degrading yeah at his own this
is how CNN's Oliver Darcy explained
what's going on in Seattle from 3,000
miles away he said if you've been
getting your news from right-wing media
you probably think our militant and Tifa
activists have seized a section of
Seattle but the mayor's office tells me
city officials have not interacted with
armed and Tifa militants at this site
well this video is what you shot from
inside this zone last night
now it doesn't exactly seem like it's
all peace and love there what were we
seeing in that video Julio
well what I could say is when President
Trump call CNN fake news there's a
reason why that insult sticks basically
what was happening there was a young man
that was surrounded by the crowd he was
accused of stealing from what I could
gather he was accused of stealing a
phone from another protester and so they
said that he was a thief and he was
trying to get away and they were asking
well if you're innocent why are you
running away from us and the man was
clearly terrified and and there at one
point there was a guy with a baseball
bat and he shoved the baseball bat in
the guy's face he said I'm gonna he said
I'm gonna beat you up so unfortunately
for that young man he was able to get
away from the crowd and it was then
discovered that he didn't actually steal
the phone the phone was discovered at
another spot so but you could imagine if
the crowd decided to use the baseball
bats against them only then for him to
find out that he didn't actually steal
anything so tense moment there were
individuals with weapons right inside
the zone because we've seen them play
but I guess CNN has trouble doing a
basic Google search on the Internet
Julio thank you so much good to see you